give me that pen over there alright so I
have another question for you is I don't
know if you know this but you can't tell
but on my face you know I'm getting old
an Asian men when they get old they get
these gigantic liver spots how the [ __ ]
do I get rid of them I I had not heard
that is are they really liver spots are
they sun spots or what are they i think
there's sons i don't think they're
related to like a liver issue i just
think they're called liver spots called
liver spots but they're like sun spots
yes sun spots yeah yeah you know i have
a few spots too so there's a variety of
treatments that you can get like plasma
injections in your face this is one way
to get rid of them and another way is to
get them lasered off so they actually
get a laser to fire them up and
basically burn that tissue off and get
it to fall off looks nice by the way
Derek I I watched your whole thing with
dr. David Sinclair about aging yeah and
it was my most favorite thing ever they
talked about how to reverse aging and
how you can be biologically 48 but be
like truly 30 years old or be 48 but be
biologically older if you don't take
care of your body it probably has to do
with being gluten free and eating longer
and all the stuff we know about living
here we go okay it's I gotta say it's
not encouraging for most lifestyles okay
cuz what you want to do is you want to
kind of trick your body into thinking
that it's gonna die that's the best way
to force your body to them serve itself
so one way you force your body to think
that it's gonna die is you donate if you
went like five days and you just drank
water that's a great trigger for all
your body's natural defenses to say whoa
hold up you know stuffs not coming in we
got a hunker down we gotta clean up all
ourselves so cells that you have that
might be precancerous or cells that you
have that might just you know be like
not the best cells you've got if you if
you starve them your body will likely
kill them and that'll like
prevent disease down the track so one
thing has been shown is yeah really
restricting your calorie intake at least
you know for periods of time that can
that can heat your body and yeah yeah
yes you can do is is get really cold
like go out somewhere and just shiver
for a while that'll help or really yeah
or sweating for a while like getting
getting really uncomfortably hot so
you're all sweating all of these things
are like signals for your body to sort
of put its mechanisms into place for for
preserving the body because the idea is
like when the times become good again
your body wants to still be there in
order to make kids so that's so Derek
Lee this is what I've always done I
haven't done it during quarantine
obviously but like you know I go to this
Korean spa this is not a joke this is
real I go to this Korean spa and they're
cold plunge is illegal it's so [ __ ]
cold right what I'll do is I'll go to
the you know I'll go to the steam room
and get as hot as I can and I'll sit in
the cold plunge up to my neck right
until it's like until I'm literally
freezing right and I sit I do that
process over and over again and I feel
you know I've been doing it for years
and that whenever I do it I feel great
my brother won't do it when we're at the
spa but I love that is that yeah yeah
absolutely well I actually asked the
this Harvard professor who I interviewed
about this I asked him specifically that
question because I've done it too and he
wouldn't give me a straight answer on it
he was giving me answers on you know
like just being cold or just being hot I
asked him do you get the benefit from
from going back and forth he didn't
answer that so like I can't give you a
definitive but like a it definitely is
getting your body to exercise those like
you know constriction of your blood
vessels and then and then dilating and
it's probably good to get your body to
sort of do that and get the blood
flowing there's one more thing I should
mention which is exercising hard like
high-intensity interval training that
seems to provide the greatest benefit as
opposed to like just going for a walk
every day or something like that you can
bring the same number of calories but if
you get on a bike or get on a treadmill
and you sprint so you're basically at
like 85 90 % of your your peak that's
really
good for you and again makes your body
feel like oh no we got a we gonna fix
stuff and you know less in general yeah
so all those things I also read so I
think I saw a document or something a
long time ago about in Okinawa they have
like the most amount of people living
over the age of a hundred and a lot of
that has to do with obviously their diet
so it's like you know they're eating
clean fish right I there's a lot of
older people that still do like spear
hunting in the ocean without any like
old school you know I mean and then
another thing was that there a sense of
community right yeah yeah it's like
people taking care of each other and the
stress levels are very low you know do
you think that that is also a factor
yeah I think there's definitely
something to that community huge issue
you want to feel like you're important
and like you're valuable and like you're
actually contributing something to
society and if you feel that I think
that that helps your body you know stay
in the game longer as well so I guess
that's it's so important for people to
have like a purpose all the way through
their lives and if you lose that that's
a that's a real problem
so you're yeah I think I think what a
killer is obviously Americans the diet
100% but but I think a lot of it also is
just in terms of lifestyle and stress
and all those things I think that all
with the things that you suggested I
think they make complete and utter sense
to me and I think alongside of being
happy and also living a stress free type
of lifestyle right and also diet I think
that that those are also keys would you
agree with me
stress-free like yeah it's some stress
in your life to get you like up and
doing things but like being active I
mean Americans just aren't great at that
and you know I I was thinking about it
myself like when was the last time you
forgot to eat it's like you know never I
never forget I eat a lot and yeah
frequently and that's kind of a problem
for our bodies because it doesn't mirror
the conditions that we would have
living in 10,000 years ago or 50,000
years ago we would have gone days
without eating no problem you know but
we never would have gone a day without
getting up you know we never would have
gone a day lying on a couch watching
Netflix because you know you don't I
mean like it's loosen some things we
totally forget to do these days any of
those sorts of things that will kill you
and whatever but what I mean by stressed
though I mean it's like if I didn't do
things that would stress me out yeah
right whatever that is is that you know
when situations arise you know not
taking things personally or not like you
know I mean getting resentment and
hatred and you know all those things
that like your body stores all that
stuff right
also trauma to get rid of all that you
know mean as well I think yeah I think
like really negative thoughts can be
negative for your body like you can have
your mental state definitely influences
you know the state of your body so being
able to find a way to be positive or to
you know that's why I think exercise is
so important as well because it allows
you to relieve some of that stress and
sort of channel it into like a healthy
energy as opposed to some sort of you
know destructive energy for your body so
yeah no I definitely I definitely agree
with you too so to manage the stress and
keep a positive outlook and have have a
good community and sort of good
relationships with other people